all right ivy
welcome back so
it's been it's been several months it's
been four or five months father you
since you were here last right
yeah what's going on um
and that's just some still judging still
thinking
are you still working yeah i'm still
working
and your daughter's with your
grandmother with her um
father my child's grubbing i mean mother
yeah
but you get to see your daughter still
yeah
yeah she's kidding big
sassy and how are you doing
um all right i'm all right i'm a lot
better
as far as like my attitude and stuff why
is that
i don't know i've been talking to my mom
more
um it's good to be in contact with her
um to see my baby grow up
i don't know things that like i seem a
bit lighter
happier pray more you don't seem as down
as you were the last couple times we've
talked
trying to smile trying to
yeah you look good you look healthy
thank you
i still smoke like smoke more but yeah
crazy i still like healthy do you think
the
the drug use is is is part of
the problem i was watching yeah i was
watching your old videos and uh
it seems like the drug use is kind of
the core of the problem
yeah it is it's definitely a problem
it doesn't it doesn't help with the
depression either does that at all
right screwing around with your brain
chemistry just can't be a good thing
yeah
which is what that does
but it allows you to do that kind of
work right
i mean i've done it sober i've done it
hi this is gonna make a difference
it makes me more i guess bold my
personality a little bit but um
yeah more bold so yeah outspoken
yeah just you need you need to be bold
to do that kind of work right
got to
tim is weak in the streets i'm sorry
you're timid it's like a sign of
weakness in that out there
yeah you can't be tempted on the street
but um yeah it's still
my drug use is messing with my
ability to be able to get my daughter
back
um so
her grandma will be taking custody of
her
and next month i'll lose my parental
rights
oh no oh yeah
so how does that affect your plans now
i never had a plan you need to have a
plan
you need to figure out what you're doing
with your life for yourself and for your
daughter
and whatever that plan is going to be
it's not going to be some small little
move it'll be something major
yeah that'll take a lot of strength and
courage yeah
i know because i feel far behind
i'm sorry i feel so far behind so it's
like
you're 20 years old right 21 now
so you're you're still a kid basically
and you have lots of years ahead of you
hold your daughter she's one
one yeah so basically you have all the
time in the world to get this right
and if you made a major move that might
impact your
income but eventually will
positively impact your child's
life and your happiness and your
stability and
everything else i think that could be a
great move but it's gonna it's gonna
take some courage to do that
yeah i've been trying to like take up
hobbies and
stuff like that like i like doing nails
i don't know it's all i've always had a
dream being a nail technician
i like doing else
any of those could be a good path to
take
do you think do you think quitting
crystal meth will be
something you can do on your own
yeah do i want to
i know
but i care i can
was you was your father ever in your
life no
[Music]
so i'm like your surrogate father now
after the last video on this one
i'm giving you all this fatherly advice
but it's really just it's just common
sense you know
you know because i've interviewed so
many like hundreds of girls that
do what you do and even the ones that
tell me they're happy
they're not i don't call them on it but
i but i listen to them
defend their lives and it's like
i don't see how a human can really be
happy
doing what you do and what would you
rather be rich or happy
happy yeah especially when
you know we got babies and
we want to be strong for our babies but
um
yeah it's hard being happy and raising a
kid i think that's why
i kind of just gave up
i had to say i gave up on my daughter
but
it's i gave up because i knew she was
gonna be okay and i prayed for it
prayed for it every day
i thank god so much because um
i'm thankful i'm lucky is she okay
you know
it's okay imagine your daughter
one day being your age and watching this
video
and hearing you struggle with your
decision
and it's up to you to make that that
change in your life
you can either continue with what you're
doing and you know where that'll lead
or you can make a big change that very
few people make
i'm like sometimes sometimes glad you
know i didn't raise it
because um
like i've been talking to myself in god
a lot it's just like
[ __ ] i try to be honest
it's like being so honest with myself is
it's kind of hurting me too because it's
like the more i'm honest with myself i
start to realize
that i'm just starting to accept the
[ __ ] like you know like yeah
i'm out here i'm getting high you know
my daughter's okay it's all right
but it's not all right
but um i'm angry i'm disappointed
but i'm happy if that makes sense what
are you happy about
i'm happy that she's not going to be
raised by a depressed
you know insecure mom
because i'm the outcome of a depressed
insecure mom being
raising a daughter on her own right but
even more important than your child i
think is
is your own well-being yeah because if
you're happy and healthy
your child is going to be happy and
healthy so if you take care of yourself
you're actually taking care of your kid
i believe
and do you want to spend the rest of
your life being depressed and angry
and lost you don't
yeah so i definitely try to talk
more let's try to just let stuff go
so i don't just sit inside of my pity
yeah but it's it's going to be up to you
to break the cycle
you know your dad wasn't around your mom
was
is your mom still working no
no she's um she's still an addict but
um but whatever your mom was not the
best role model
you can put it that way but it's not her
fault you know
she's one of the reasons but she's just
not
the fault for my decisions
so it's good that you're taking
[Music]
responsibility
but at some point you need to really
take the reins and just
steer your life in a very different
direction and maybe it's one that you're
that you haven't seen before your
siblings aren't doing it and your mom
didn't do it and your dad didn't do it
yeah my sister um i got a call a couple
weeks ago my sister she just went to
prison for murder
and my sister was you know she was
she's [ __ ] up in the head well messed
up
every drug you name it she did it and um
i knew one day she was gonna snap
but to actually get the call was coming
it's kind of crazy
just like don't let it be me because
you get tired of you know the men
you know out there roughing you up
you know arguing fighting you know
just to get a little paper
you know when i wake up in the morning
like
not today you know i hope the day after
that i gotta keep
the focus what do you think it is
you're chasing money so you can get your
drug
so you can just stay on that cycle that
keeps you away from your daughter
it leaves you with no no good options
for your future
i think the last time we spoke you said
you're actually saving money
yeah are you still saving money
[Music]
and on top of that it's such a dangerous
lifestyle that
i watched a man die for the first time
and uh so i had to
i happened to be there you know when it
happened
and he died in my arms
um
and it was scary as [ __ ]
who is this um so
i know a known guy in in the area of
south central and um
i just heard a gunshot go off and
i saw him running i knew him and
i just held him i don't have to do
i just held them
and i was here so i have to leave my
room
um leave that area i just didn't want to
be a part of the politics and the
talking and
i didn't want to be around it anymore so
yeah it's like situation after situation
and i keep catching myself in these
crazy eye situations and it's like
when is this [ __ ] going to stop it's not
it's not
so it's up to one person to make it stop
and you're gonna have to make a bold
move
that'll probably be difficult at first
but it'll feel you feel really good two
three years later
to stick with it
i know you're young now but you know
you'll be 30 40
50 eventually and nothing will have
changed
i'm sorry i don't want to feel that path
alone
i want to be on the right path nobody i
know is on the right path
your friend megan seems to be
she's a good girl
she's one of the very few that's
actually doing some things to change her
situation and her situation's similar to
yours
looks like i'm so beautiful i'm so smart
i'm so talented
yeah you're all those things but when
it's when it comes down to like
actually getting my [ __ ] together i get
stuck
what i hear from a lot of people that
have made the change is
you just can't you just get tired of all
the [ __ ]
because there's a lot of it doing this
kind of work
and once you get tired of it and you
just draw the line you won't tolerate it
anymore
that's when you'll do it and that'll
mean stopping the drugs it'll mean
finding a new way to support yourself
those are really hard decisions scary
right
scared
whatever you're going to do to make
yourself happy is going to require
courage that's all i can tell you
you're not just going to be happy
because you got lucky
it's going to require courage in some
form
because i really want my baby back
that sure hurts man
it's a different kind of pain
not to hold my baby no more
i [ __ ] hate myself every day
and probably your guilt and shame makes
you
just want to get high more
being pretty and don't get you that far
you know like
sometimes everybody just don't get to
float through life
whatever kids tell you so beautiful
you're so beautiful but
when you don't feel beautiful inside it
really doesn't
mean anything
some of the most attractive people i've
met are the most self-destructive people
i've met
yeah yeah
another question to ask yourself is you
want to be attractive or you want to be
happy
i'd rather be happy right i want to feel
happiness
real happiness
i just gotta get tired of it the missing
the missing
part of the puzzle here is courage yeah
because the moves you're going to have
to make are going to require courage
you're going to have to take a risk make
some bold moves that are going to
sound crazy and feel scary
but that's that's what it's going to
require
i think it's good that you're actually
asking or talking about these kind of
things
you're asking these questions you're
you're talking about it because
and that's why i like that you do this
because it's like
success imagine sitting in a room
with 20 people that are doing the same
[ __ ] that you're doing
getting high you know running the
streets
like do you really think i want to talk
to you
about my problems when
you are going through 10 times worse so
it's like
yeah i let my emotions out a lot
on my alone time when when it's quiet
but the people you're hanging out with
might be keeping you down too
i mean i'm an introvert so i don't
really
i'm not social butterfly
so when i do feel my emotions
i feel them hard
that just means you have the ability to
channel
all that energy all that emotional
energy into something positive
if you can just because you're an
introvert doesn't mean you can't do
great things
it just means that your
your energy your emotions are all inside
and you can channel that into some kind
of positivity some kind of
something to find the courage to do what
you need to do
because i can see you very clearly in my
imagination living a great life being
with your daughter
having a job being stable
not using i can see that so so easily
for you
smiling being happy spending time with
your with your daughter
it's easy to imagine but
if you're running the streets hanging
out with people that are doing the exact
same thing everyone's using drugs
everyone's sharing stories about the
crazy [ __ ] that happens on the streets
it's like that's not going to get you
anywhere
no one doing that is happy even the ones
that tell you they're happy are not
happy
and the fact you might use your rights
to visit your your daughter
coming up gives you every reason to do
it sooner than later right
yeah yeah
there'll be a court date coming up yeah
in march
march
so
i think you have all the tools and
intelligence and everything you need to
do what you need to do
you just need the courage to do it and
no one's going to give you the courage
i can't do it your boyfriend can't do it
no one can do it
we can support you we can tell you
you're doing the right thing but
it's going to be up to you to
do it yeah
i got two i got two you do
and again it's not for your daughter
it's for you
because if you do it for you who's going
to benefit most
your daughter and you so don't do it
don't do it for someone else do it for
yourself because you deserve it
your daughter wants you to be happy
everyone around you wants to be happy
yeah i have no choice but to do better
well it's not about having no choices
it's just about doing the right thing
because i don't know
not doing anything to help myself
that's some guilt i don't think i can
i don't i could handle that
just keep in mind that the family you
came from the environment you're in
none of it really supports you doing
what you need to do what
you have no role models that did this
you have no
i don't know if you have any friends
that have done it megan has done it
that's the only one i can think of
that i know you know she seems to be
doing the right thing
and it's hard
[Music]
you should give megan a call or devin is
her video's title
give her a call and uh just
bounce some ideas off of her because she
has courage and she has intelligence and
beauty like you do
but she's doing it and so far you're not
and that's a big deal
maybe you can learn something from her
i hope you find the courage darling
because my life hasn't been
that tragic you know i haven't
been through most i heard so many people
go through so many things
but that's how i realized
you know depression is real
it'll take you to some places that you
never wanted to be never could have
imagined
so you know it takes me you know
i gotta start to love myself
i got to that's the secret to everything
that's the answer and that's what'll
bring you the courage
that'll help you make the right
decisions
because i ain't going to live like this
no one does
i'd love to see you make some changes
that'd be great
can you imagine what your life might be
like if you got your life straight and
you got your daughter back and did all
that kind of stuff
yeah that's good i dream about it every
day
yeah that's great you're smiling
keep that keep that in your mind
and just do things that are gonna lead
there
all right abby well thank you for coming
by again thank you so much
and i i hope the next month for you is
is different
keep some of these things we talked
about in your in your head and it's
it's it's kind of time to do things and
make some changes
while you're still young yeah
how many 30 40 50 year old ladies have i
interviewed that are
been doing this since they were
teenagers and they're still doing it now
and they
they're not getting out the only time
they get out is when they're forced out
because they're
too old right yeah
[Music]
i'd love to see you smile more
encourage you'll bring that
thank you all right thanks john
thank you party
you can do this you can do it
you